what end of shift Mikhail did a terrible
job today hopefully no patients suffered
due to his negligence I haven't seen a
patient in person for about a month
because we moved all our encounters to
Virtual visits and I'm itching to see a
patient I feel like the only way I can
make that happen is through live
vicariously through a Sim okay how do we
change things I gotta make the face
legit
wait it keeps putting female characters
genetics no I don't want to create her
child dark brown oh what you can change
mouth this is weird can I undo yeah I'm
more pale I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
give it into the paleness and really
lean into the
pale self that I am oh
tucked in button up dude this guy looks
like me right now dude this is how I
dress for work this is legit me yeah
this is me this is legit me this is what
I wore to work but let me get me buff
yeah that's he's a little thick ah
mazarps
did he just say nice arms okay if I was
creating a place to live I would want to
live in the most secluded place as
possible should we go for an expensive
one or should we do like a fixer-upper
Let's do let's do like let's ball out
let's go twin Oracle Point wait how do
you build a building
how do I just build a home oh you build
a room by room let's get a bedroom
simple sleeper or do I want something
fancy dreams from the future looks like
my current yeah
I dig it let's let's build it right in
the middle so if you want to come here
you have to go all the way through
everything what else do you need to make
a home a home you probably need a
kitchen right should the kitchen be near
the bedroom I feel like it needs a
little room to breathe bathroom you need
a bathroom bathrooms I like to keep it
simple you don't need to spend a lot of
money for a bathroom it's Bare
Necessities at this point I agree but
the bathroom has to be attached to the
bedroom or at least close to the bedroom
so you have access boom living room I
like it I you know you want something
that brings people together but I have
no more money just keep it simple for
now this is where I entertain so you
want this close to the front of the
house okay I have no more money
so I guess I have to go to work oh I'm a
medical assistant making 35 an hour
vacation days three I have work in 24
hours because it is Sunday I work Sunday
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday why am
I not working today ideal mood is focus
kiss my performance is average we got to
step that up and to get promoted I have
to treat three patients I think I can do
it for now how do you become a better
person let's get in good shape let's get
let's get Dr Mike here jogging we are in
quarantine just make sure you jog
somewhere around your house where you're
socially distancing yourself whoa whoa
whoa buddy buddy buddy we gotta change
your outfit
we gotta change your outfit wait was I
supposed to create different outfits for
this fella what are his needs what are
your needs but Kyle go home what's on
his phone oh my God you can check your
social media timeline oh my God
this game's a Savage it's only 12 p.m
don't you dare go napping his house is
not fancy where are people in this game
can he go to the park oh he can play as
a sea monster
is it weird that a doctor is going to
play in a children's playground
but at the same time if an outsider saw
this
okay enough go home I'm just excited for
him to go to work let's fast forward we
need to see those patients it's about
being a doctor oh who's this guy
uh in funny introduction who is this guy
Mortimer goth look we're chatting it up
why is my bladder full oh he's getting
hungry do I have anything in the fridge
oh he's cooking he acquired the cooking
skill definitely not something I have in
real life if you saw my sous vide
cooking video I'm sorry sleep
time for you to sleep it's 9 p.m get
that early to bed early to rise money oh
look he woke up happy while he sleeps in
pink pants but let's see what he does in
the hospital that's what I'm most is he
going jogging I know he's eating he's
making breakfast yeah yeah I get it he
has needs what about hygiene he needs to
take a shower he took a bubble bath he
woke up at 5am to take a bubble bath
what is he a psychopath mikhail's
Hospital shift is starting now care to
join him or should Mikhail go to work
alone
oh no I think we're joining
my man doesn't have
[Music]
doesn't Hospital be serious swab a
patient for a sample
let's go see these coveted patients how
do you scan a patient's body this is
weird let's treat him
treat bloaty head with shot
Sims
bloaty head with shot I've never
committed medical malpractice until now
bloaty head you know what the real
disease here is this non-matching scrubs
outfit with a maroon top and green
bottoms refer X-Ray Scan let's go talk
to this gentleman yeah bring them to an
x-ray oh my God this x-ray machine looks
like it's a TSA scanner right there
that is not an extra that looks like
some kind of alien technology if we have
that in the future that's cool Mikhail
has successfully performed a practice
examination the test results seem valid
but specific data is a bit over his head
and will be passed along to a physician
for diagnosis it's a good learning
experience though bro I'm the game
doesn't know what I know but I know that
bloody head ain't a real thing just
saying wait wait let's get these
patients in dude you're the medical
assistant stop talking to them and check
them [ __ ] said oh I got like this line
for me Mike Mike Mike check the patience
in buddy uh he's hungry he's getting a
little snack for himself in the
microwave is it lunchtime even or is he
just eating like a Savage no it's one
o'clock we need to find out what's wrong
with this lady once you check her in
we're gonna we're gonna make a hospital
out of this place we'll make a hospital
of it yet okay let's see romance no we
do not romance our patients as Mama Dr
Jones and I have said oh there we go uh
swab for sample what is he swabbing for
you think it's covid what
end of shift Mikhail did a terrible job
today hopefully no patients suffered due
to his negligence I didn't know what I
was supposed to do this is messed up
this is what I don't like jobs where the
directions are unclear and I'm supposed
to just know where I'm supposed to be
maybe tell me what my duties are lay out
my responsibilities so that I can
execute I shouldn't have done a terrible
job I'm literally gonna fast forward
till the next day just so I can come
back to work
I don't even care what happens the rest
of the day fast forward let them do
whatever he wants he's uncomfortable I
know why he's uncomfortable because he
did a poop job at work today I don't I
literally don't care Monday could just
pass right now if I could just skip to
next day oh look a viable tissue sample
was successfully collected now Mikhail
must test it in the chemical analyzer
didn't do it because I didn't know whoa
Rhys fibu would like to come over and
hang out
that's the patient Crossing Lines here
Reese chill I'm not even gonna pick up
on her all right yeah sleep Mike because
you're gonna need to show up to work
tomorrow and actually perform
because whatever that was today was
nonsense he earned forty two dollars bro
if you make forty two dollars a day how
are you gonna pay off your medical loans
the average medical student graduates
with like 275 000 in loans 42 dollars a
day
do better Mike assigned to right side of
the bed what am I not allowed on the
left side of the bed because bear has it
by the way there's going to be multiple
sins I'm gonna create bear I'm gonna
create my daddy's gonna live next to me
I'm gonna build out a whole Community
you're not ready for this we're gonna
take over this town we're gonna call it
varshovsky's work starts in one hour
yeah
that's why I'm trying to fast forward to
all I care about is the job
all right Mike let's do it today let's
do a better job than we did yesterday
let's check in some patience uh where's
the bathroom he needs to use the
bathroom although if you're a really
good employee you should probably use
the bathroom before you get to work okay
his bladder is now empty let's see some
patience we're analyzing a sample log
the sample results
okay where do we log them donate to
unlock sample results look at that
[Music]
figuring it out making stuff happen
why am I cleaning the bathroom
[Music]
okay let's swap wait I already did swab
a patient for a sample scan a patient's
body come on Mike come on Mike you're
going the wrong way buddy
I don't understand why is he cleaning up
the exercise room check eyes there we go
oh look he did it
[Music]
okay check a patient's ears oh my God
Rhys the person who called the doctor
that wanted to hang out was a child
that's weird
Mike
don't don't invite children to your home
and you don't need to eat today Mike end
of shift Mikhail did an adequate job
today preventive care is the best course
so he needs to step it up look I made
224 dollars today and adequate is better
than poop what I got last time we got to
adequate job I want to crush day three I
also want to build up my house I don't
know what that sad excuse for a home is
doesn't even have a roof I want to get
bare I want to get Roxy I want to get my
dad if you're with me on that Journey
smash the like button let me know in the
comment section if you want to have a
good laugh check out this responding to
onion headlines video that I made right
here or one of my favorite playlists of
me reacting to Medical memes you don't
laugh at these you don't have a senses
of humor get it senses fill out your
senses today
foreign
[Music]